this is Jocko podcast number 177 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening a few days
later when I walked downstairs to go
work out
I saw uncle Jake's bag packed up sitting
by the door that's when it hit me the
summer was almost over and Uncle Jake
was leaving again I went out to the
garage to work out and Uncle Jake was
already there last workout with me for
the summer he said with a smile I can't
believe it's over already summer always
goes by so fast I told him yes it does
uncle Jake said quietly and life does
the same thing I wasn't sure what Uncle
Jake meant by that so I asked what
you'll see mark he said life goes by
quickly like a summer day it never seems
that way when you're young but when you
get a little older you'll see life goes
by fast so don't waste any time you
don't get a second chance Uncle Jake
stood for a minute looking at me with a
serious face then he gave me a little
smile and said speaking of wasting time
let's stop wasting time and get this
workout done he jumped up on the pull-up
bar grabbed hold and started knocking
them out and that is a little excerpt
from the last chapter in a new book the
latest edition in the series way the
warrior could kid book 3 the subtitle
the book is where there is a will and I
wrote that part of the book because I
wanted to let kids know as early as
possible that that is the truth
that life goes by like a summer day and
the life is short
and if you remember when you were a kid
and summer you get out of school for the
summer and it seems like you have all
the time in the world it seems like
summer vacation is gonna last forever
and then all of a sudden that's blurred
and you look up and as soon as summer
vacation has started all of a sudden
it's over that's what I remember about
summers and that's the truth
and that's what life is like about a
year and a half ago September 29th the
2017 and September 29th is st. Michael's
Day that's the day that Mikey Mansour
was killed in Ramadi in 2006 so on
September 29th 2017 I woke up and I was
thinking about that and I was thinking
about Mikey and later that day I think I
was actually heading up to Rosecrans
National Cemetery where Mikey is buried
and I was gonna go and visit Mikey's
grave and while I was on my way up there
I got a call and I found out that one of
my mentors one of the guys that raised
me in the SEAL Teams a guy named Master
Chief Mike faculty he had died and he
had been in a pretty hardcore battle
with lung cancer even though he was a
nonsmoker even though he's a triathlete
even though he worked out all the time
he got this form of lung cancer and
originally the doctors told him he was
gonna live for six months but that was
in I think 2012 he had retired in 2001
and I sitting there thinking about
faculty and actually btf Tony talked
about him called him FAC when he was on
the podcast because we all called him
FAC but I remembered
just a bunch of different things about
FAQ and one of the things that I
remembered was I had come back from my
third deployment so this is in the 90s
back in the day and I had done my third
deployment and I had been moved into the
training department at SEAL team 1 so
instead of doing a workup and going on
deployment the way the teams used to be
set up you would you would go into
training cell and the team trained
itself
the training department at SEAL team 1
trained to the platoons at SEAL team 1
later it became that we had a big
centralized Training Command that's what
I ran before I got out before I retired
I ran that the trade at on the west
coast but it used to be each team had
their own training cell and that's how
you would train platoons to get ready
for their deployments and of course
nobody really wanted to be in training
cell because it meant you couldn't go on
deployment and that's why you joined the
SEAL team assist to go on deployment and
for whatever reason we in a bunch of us
from my platoon that I'd gone through
buds with a bunch of guys we'd all done
three platoons that kind of we all kind
of got thrown into training cell at the
same time and we'd been in there for a
couple days I mean maybe less than a
week we come back from deployment we'd
get put into training cell and I kind of
forget what happened but a couple guys
that were getting ready to deploy got
hurt in fact it might have been guys had
gotten hurt as soon as they got over
there maybe they didn't go on deployment
the guys that went and replaced us all
of a sudden they needed a couple guys
and that quarters in the morning that's
when you at SEAL team one they used to
have quarters in the morning where you
all just stand up and line up sort of
like your typical military formation
everyone would kind of line up and by
platoon and the platoons would all
report in that was an old-school team
one deal right there and then if there
was any important announcements to make
then the announcements would get made
and then everyone would go about their
day well the announcement that got made
that morning was hey we need two guys to
go on two
is there anyone here that feels like
going on deployment or can go on
deployment and and of course it's a big
deal right to just pick up and go and
leave for six months and it was actually
my roommate at the time who had been my
roommate who I went through buds with
and who I did three platoons with and
went through SEAL tactical training with
with him and we were actually roommates
that entire time so we were on people
work tight you my brother and when they
asked this question of hey is there
anybody here that can go on deployment
like tomorrow or the next day and
basically out of the whole team it was
him and me we raised our hand said yeah
hey we'll go because at that time you
know we were just single team guys we
didn't have anything else we literally
had nothing else you could put our whole
world into two crews boxes and we could
ship anywhere in the world we didn't
care we had no attachments we had didn't
care about anything so of course we
raised her hands and as soon as her
hands went up Master Chief faculty gave
us a glare because he was the guy that
was in charge of training cell so he
gave us a glare and corners ended and he
cuz he said hey what you guys come
upstairs and talk to me real quick
and I was thinking okay we must have
done something wrong and you sometimes
you didn't know what you did wrong but I
me and my buddy we figured we'd done
something wrong so we went up there and
actually actually now that I think about
it we he brought us into the Chiefs mess
and we were like ephors or e5s at the
time and so goal getting pulled into the
Chiefs Chiefs mess I'd never been in
there before and I was like scared
thinking what did I thought I did
something wrong I thought that I left a
trail of some crime I'd committed and
now we're getting busted and we get up
there and basically he reamed us out and
he says listen you guys need to be in
training so and he was making great
points I didn't recognize that time you
know as it looks if you want to be
professionals if this is where you're
gonna learn a lot
we need good guys to be teaching the
rest of the platoons that's why you're
in here you're not going on deployment
shut up and I'm pulling your names out
of the Hat and they'll find two other
people that can go we'll send some new
guys over there doesn't matter
so that's what it was that was this
little story it was big funny because
you know we were it was just funny from
multiple reasons when I thought back
about just the fact that you're in a
point in your life I think I was
probably like 23 or 24 years old and
just just think about right now if
someone says hey can you just leave for
six months tomorrow mmm
I mean there's not too many people that
could just pull up and do that so
there's that there's the fact that you
know faculty was bringing us into the
Chiefs mess and we were all nervous
about that and then the fact that you
know faculty what he was actually doing
was trying to look out for us and trying
to look out for our careers and trying
to look out for the SEAL team he was
trying to do the right thing and it was
one of those one of those little stories
and there's just all these little
stories like that that make up that
whole era of my life the whole time as a
young enlisted guide SEAL team on its
this whole bunch of memories and when he
died I got this feeling that those
memories those those days are over like
they're gone because at least partially
because when FAC was around like a part
of those memories are facts memories
like only he could tell us what he was
thinking at that time and when he dies
when he died then didn't those memories
are gone and look I can't ask him about
him I can't go and have a beer with him
and talk about that time and hear his
side of it like no there they're not
here they're gone and as I was you know
again going up to see Mikey Mansour at
Rosecrans and I continued to think about
that and thinking about the memories
that might be had and how those are
going
but I didn't have too much time to dig
into those thoughts because the next
morning September 30th 2017 that's when
I got word that the Delta platoon
commander my brother Seth stone had died
as well and all kinds of memories died
with him I mean I got my half of him
about it's half it's incomplete
conversations and jokes and guitar jams
and then on top of those I get little
but Seth was incredibly smart and he'd
give me little ideas little thoughts but
only the beginning of because there's
millions of things to talk about you
think you got your whole life to to
consider those things but you don't and
I get that we can try and talk about
them we can try and write them down and
we can do everything you know our power
to to try and hang on to those things
but the fact of the matter is you you
can't you can't preserve them in their
true form it's just gone
and as I thought about that and as I
continue to think about that and try and
figure out what can we do if we can't
preserve these memories then what can we
do I mean I think the best thing that we
can do is try and make more try and make
more make more memories so so keep in
mind what Uncle Jake said life goes by
like a summer day
so you better take advantage of it when
your best to make yourself some memories
along the way and with that echo yes
it's been a little while since we did
some Q&A yes sir
what do you got I've got some questions
from the interwebs all right
we'll go into it first question what do
you do when the boss always says we
can't but doesn't offer logical and
reasonable alternatives to make positive
forward changes should one just do what
they think is best and not listen to the
boss okay first of all what we want to
do is we want to support the boss I'm
gonna build a relationship with the boss
what's the best way to support the boss
for the best way to build a relationship
is to be a performer be a performer
inside the box right that the boss has
said you can't do this you can't do that
cool we're gonna do the best we can in
side the box and once you do that once
you once you actually once you actually
are a performer then you have leverage
then you can actually talk about a
different way of doing things you can
bring up a legitimate idea to the boss
and they may will they have a better
chance of listening to you so that's
what you got to do you got to play the
game a little bit you got to you got to
become a performer you got to do what it
is the way they want it done to the best
of your ability be successful with it
and then once you've built up some clout
and some relationship and maybe a little
political capital then you can present a
new idea and when you present the new
idea have the facts lined up don't go in
there half-cocked and present your idea
and hopefully gets cleared now that's
what that's section a section B is do
you gotta make things happen sometimes
you and depending on how like it's that
whole thing of
it's better to beg forgiveness than ask
for permission that's a that's a it's
it's it's a it's a tool it's definitely
a tool if you abuse it you're gonna get
crushed if it's one of those things
where the the boss has told you not to
do something and you decide well I'm
gonna do it anyways and I'll just beg
for forgiveness no they actually told
you not to do it that's not where you're
supposed to use that tool yeah that's
just that's just that's just unset right
under that if it's something where well
I kind of suspect that the boss might
not want it this way but you know what
chances are it's gonna go in my
direction and chances are it's gonna be
beneficial and chances are the boss
might not even find out and if the boss
does find out this isn't something that
they've ever declared hostile so you'll
be okay in that situation too to beg for
forgiveness but don't abuse that tool
and then what you do is you start if
when you're inside the hey I'm gonna beg
for forgiveness then you can start
actually doing something in developing a
standard operating procedure that makes
sense and then once you get it
solidified you go to the boss and say
hey boss we've been doing this a
different way I want to let you know I
want to show you what we've been doing
because we you know you know boss we
never really had a specific way of
getting this done and I know some other
people did it like this and some people
did it like that we came up with a
methodology actually wrote the whole
thing out for you so you can see exactly
what we're doing boom who's gonna say no
to that plus it's been successful 80
times boom we're good so so that's what
you want to do that's pretty pretty
straight forward don't don't just
straight disobey the boss unless the
boss is telling you to do something's
gonna get someone killed or illegal or
whatever mm-hm but if they're just have
a different idea or something just go
with it
execute it become a good performer and
then once you have that relationship
built you'll have all kinds of influence
over your boss always had crazy
influence over my bosses yeah I don't
wanna sound I don't say in an arrogant
way I wasn't like I was manipulating my
bosses but my boss is like I was honest
with my bosses and they I did good work
and so when I said hey boss
are we sure we should do it this way
they'd be like what do you think well
here's what I think we'd get shit done
so pretty straightforward
pretty straightforward yeah that asking
for forgivness thing risky move he's not
a risky move it sometimes it's a great
great move yeah if you kind of like how
you said like don't abuse it where you
know there's levels to it yeah where
there's like little things Larry to
levels so like if you if there's one
that's like how you said like he told
you not only and this goes for like
anyone like your anyone you're dealing
with like your even your friends kind of
thing you know where are they if you
know for a fact that they don't want you
to do it so that's why you prefer not to
ask for permission because you know
they're gonna say no but you know like
right you shouldn't do that you know
that yeah but if it's the kind where
it's like I can see why he'd want to do
it maybe this way or maybe not even
necessarily want to do that this way
because maybe he doesn't see the
benefits that we see right now but and
he's closed-minded he's you know he has
that reputation so let's let's sort of
do it how you said successfully you know
kind of thing so and then that's on the
other side of the spectrum you know but
some people men they'll just like take
it to level five or whatever and be like
oh yeah they're gonna hate this boss
better dose for forgiveness or producing
that's a guarantee no and forgiveness at
least I think of but Bry you're gonna
damage the relationship if you do that
and stuff then you're gonna get
tightened down on yeah yeah oh yeah man
it's true don't don't let that happen
next question I'm the youngest leader in
my firm's history I try and implement
extreme ownership and default
aggressiveness in my team being so young
some of my elder subordinates sometimes
dismiss my directives how do I leave
this effectively okay so I actually hate
when I get this question or questions
like this because it means that I've
screwed up that's sort of he's I don't
like to screw up but when I see a
question like this it means that
somebody has misinterpreted the message
a little bit they haven't read the
dichotomy leadership for sure and in my
opinion because if you read the
dichotomy leadership you'll see that
extreme ownership and default aggressive
are supposed to be balanced mm-hmm and
so that's what's going on here you got
someone that's like you know what I'm
going to take extreme ownership hey
we're doing this my way
this
the boss I'm a leader and that's just
horrible and everyone hates you so bro
you're young they don't hate you because
you're young they're not mad at you
because you're an experienced they don't
dismiss you because because you are a
decade younger than that's not why it's
happening it's happening because you are
lacking humility you haven't built up
any relationship with these people you
haven't built up any leadership capital
with them you haven't asked them how
they think they should do things you
haven't asked them what they've been
doing for the last 22 years while you
were gonna middle school right so come
in be humble them the best way to gain
respect from people this is what's hard
to do this what's hard to understand you
want people to respect you ask them a
question
listen to what they have to say mm-hm
listen to their opinion if they come up
with a good plan use their plan the
worst way to gain respect from people is
to go in and demand respect from people
is to go in and say I'm implementing
default to krispy not heard of that you
never read extreme ownership have you
I'll tell you what that's the way we're
dealing it here I'll get you a copy so
you can read up and get on board with my
program these are all bad so I'm not
trying to say you sound just like that
but you might sound something like that
and you don't need to be too far off
that so appreciate that you're getting
after it but what you need to get after
more is some balance be humble listen to
the team listen to what they have to say
ask for their input follow very
important that's a little black belt
move it's a little black belt it's
actually a blue belt move but blue belt
purple belt move like hey my team gives
me input I listen to them mmm we
actually you know hey echo how do you
think which I think we should attack
this target from the north okay sounds
good why don't we roll with that that's
a Bluebell move man
what's it what's a white belt move
negative no the white belt moves like
hey echo we're doing this we're
attacking his target from the south I'm
gonna questions and you're like well I
think I could did from the north might
be a little bit better that might be
what you think but that's not what we're
doing
plus I'm in charge because I got
ownership of this whole thing
I'm default aggressive so do what I said
so don't be that guy man try and back
off a little bit try and form as a
leader you should be looking at like you
one of your primary goals primary call
you used to form a relationship with
your team with the people in her team so
get it done
I remember in jujitsu one time Craig
McIntyre Gregory yes he he he was
teaching to move and the move that he
was teaching he apparently got from me
and so he was teaching this move or
whatever and you know I sit in their
world and he was TV Tatia Tatia Tatia
guitar way better than I could teach
like yeah way better
in fact he taught it I simply probably
could not teach this move in here and
after he was done he was like hey echo
does his move really good to the class I
could I could do you have anything to
add to them it was like huh I know I
don't I don't remember if I did I don't
think I did but just that feeling you
know he included me and if you know a
man it was so empowering you know you
know it was you know any in his minor
and I actually thinking back and in my
mind like that it that was kind of my
move you know yeah what move over is it
gives a card past move okay
come on I always do to you yeah but
nonetheless like just how you say like
how you asked their input kind of things
like you include them in the thing and
that's not just asking it it's actually
receiving it and implementing it that's
the that's the kick that's the closure
of the move man yeah that's the closure
of the move bro I talked about like a
feeling and granted me and Gregor good
friends anyway but I'm just saying like
you can imagine that situation how that
how anyone would feel when you
especially if you're older than this
little young buck who does he think he
is and it comes to you you're like all
hell yeah okay this guy knows like you
know we can we can do this together
you know you know really get that
feeling I would imagine anyway that's
what you want to do mister youngest
leader in your firm's history Dan
Congrats on that yeah Congrats on your
getting after it what got you there may
not get you to the next level what got
you there might have been like being
aggressive and making things happen and
steppin up that's cool but if you piss
off everyone in your department
that's not gonna work out good for you
they'll start to undermine you they'll
sabotage you so you gotta be careful I
mean okay is there a possibility that
everyone in the department you got put
in there to straighten things out that's
a different question
that's a different question let me tell
you something else when you're getting
when people are dismissing what you're
saying that's a horrible sign I'm one of
the leadership books that we covered the
rule was don't give commands that you
that will that aren't going to be
followed because every time you give a
command that that you know isn't gonna
be followed that's not gonna work out
good for you it's reinforcing the fact
that no one needs to listen to you so
don't don't be giving orders that are
being dismissed if somebody doesn't do
something you go hey man I know that I
might have come across a little wrong
when I was talking to you about you know
getting this done this product just part
of this task done and I see it's still
not done is there is there some support
that you need for me is there some help
that you need for me because this is
importantly I probably and do a good job
of explaining why it's important but
it's actually connected to this larger
project that we're doing over at
headquarters and this is our part of the
task and I don't think I explained that
very well but do you need anything else
for me to to maybe move this along
you can't just allow things to be for
you to talk to treated give directions
and they just get blown off yeah like
that's not good and I'm what I'm not
saying is oh you blew off my order now
I'm gonna go high order on you but
that's not what I'm saying yeah yeah
that makes sense to Koosman if I had a
boss who else I was primed to dismiss
any of his directives yeah and it
happened and it happened successfully
like it's missed it and there was really
no real repercussions oh you better
believe I'm picking and choosing what
I'm following by the way that's not that
he's testing the envelope anyway she's
testing to see nobody can get away with
but cuz you cease your young yeah the
wrong one in here think he's gonna tell
me what to do watch this yeah and listen
to you okay cool now if you fly off the
handle and go nuts you know what you'll
get them to do it immediately yeah and
then guess what you're gonna get
undermined you get usurped you're gonna
get they're gonna have the project fail
just so they can get rid of you they're
gonna laugh at you
as the as you're getting walked out by
the HR department so you gotta be
careful man you got to be careful that's
what I'm saying
balance these things out balance extreme
ownership get the book that gotta be
leadership that's what it's about it's
about being balanced cool question Jocko
what do you do when people treat you
like a doormat and then when you finally
put your foot down they lose their minds
I try to be agreeable but there's a
limit when I stand my ground people are
act shocked in the advice yeah so this
is actually kind of the same thing right
you'd need to be balanced because what's
happening with this dude I assume is
that sitting around getting getting like
a pushover like a doormat people are
kind of walking all over then all of a
sudden he does a instant 180 and goes it
puts his foot down right and now you
think that they're gonna do a 180 you
think that they're gonna say oh sorry I
didn't mean - oh sorry echo I didn't I
didn't know that that offended you I'm
sorry no when you do that they're like
what's wrong with you you know you just
started tripping yeah yeah you're
freaking out over nothing so of course
when you stand their ground they're
gonna be shocked right which is what
you're saying happened this is like no
surprise at all so what you need to do
is is draw the line a little bit earlier
but without going nuts and I think I got
a good example of how you do this okay
let's say you got a dog and the dog is
like kind of mellow and happy and just
doesn't just all good and then like all
of a sudden you know you're walking by
the dog one day and wow it bites you on
the arm like like big time yeah big time
how do you feel about that dog yeah bad
I don't like that about that dogs
getting put down Yeah right
just this dog right let's say a bit one
of your kids oh yeah that dogs getting
put down okay so that's that's what this
guy is doing all acting all like
everything's like nothing bothering me
and all of a sudden biting people think
about what a dog like a normal dog does
what a normal dog does is its if it
starts getting offended a little bit it
starts getting problems it's it like
stands up a little bit right and then
it's gonna it's gonna growl
now that's an indicator so even a kid
even a child knows I don't know what age
but pretty young kids know that a
growling dog is a is is a warning what
else do dogs do dogs show their teeth
that's another warning like hey that's
another line in the sand mm-hmm
and and barking right because you have
to bark and I mean a dog barks at you in
a dog barks unit it's got your attention
it's growling at you you know what's
gonna happen next if you keep doing
whatever it is you're doing right you're
gonna get back away from that dog now if
you did or if the bug dog did all those
things to you and then it bit you you'll
still be mad at but you at least know
you kind of had it coming right right
yes sir
so so there you go that's what this dude
needs to do a little bit of he needs to
learn how to growl a little bit mm-hmm
how it'll bark a little how to show your
teeth little how to just stand up
posture correct because there's you know
a dog if you know dogs at all dogs have
a posture mm-hmm and they have a posture
their ears are down and they're there
their tails down when when they get
fired up boom
ears are up they're on alert that back
is they get the cackles can stand up and
everything that means like okay that's
easy that's even before growling that's
happening alert so this dude needs to
learn how to come to an alert improve
his paw increase his posture in those
moments not when it's getting too far
but like when someone need when somebody
gives you a little jab you know you
can't bite them you got a little give a
little growl yeah back them off a little
bit you know and again this is I don't
know you you know so it's hard for me to
say some people just have a hard time
dealing with when people harass them yes
because I think the best thing to do
when somebody makes fun of me is just to
like the hats yeah good one you know
like because you know just like we were
talking about before we started this
podcast if I let you know that whatever
you just said to me bothers me bro I can
expect you to just keep getting after
that until I snapped so you got to be
careful you don't want to be all hyper
sense of the other thing to remember is
man when people are making fun of you
it's not like they hate you most of the
time yeah you know it's it's not that
big of a deal like people talk smack to
each other yeah right people talk smack
to each other and and I guarantee this
is this is this is a good way to think
about it if someone talks smack to you
if you in and then you both leave let's
say it's at work you go home the other
person that was talking smack goes home
you go home you're thinking about it
that person that was talking smack
didn't think about it one millisecond
after he left the office he doesn't care
he's not sitting there thinking about
you he's not thinking like men man I'm
really glad I told you know he had a
funny looking eyebrows that was awesome
I can't believe no weird his eyebrows
are like I mean that's like he's not
doing that right he's not even thinking
about it
he just went home he's carrying on his
life carry on with your life don't get
all tied up about what these other
people are thinking of you it's not that
big of a deal don't sit around thinking
about it's it's a it's a perception that
we have that the whole world revolves
around us and then people are sitting
around thinking about us all the time
it's like they're not thinking about you
all the time they don't care they're
there at home there's not too many
people that are actually thinking about
you all the time especially if they're
making fun of you like they're they're
not thinking about that all the time so
just relax take a wrap off and just you
know try and have a little bit less
tension and you know and try and learn
to growl a little bit or at least
protect your space a little bit and
these are kind of contrary contradictory
things that I'm saying
one of them's like hey laughs out of the
other ones I kind of learned to growl a
little bit I would say first the first
method is better the first method is
like hey just laugh it off don't worry
about it
these people aren't thinking about you
they don't care then probably it's like
when we had jordan peterson as he was
talking about his friend lunch bucket
right lunch bucket the guy that worked
in and as soon as everyone realized that
it bothered him that they called him
lunch bucket that everyone just called
him lunch bucket and then they he quit
because he couldn't handle it so they'll
be if you if someone calls you lunch
bucket nicole yeah my mom makes a good
sandwich mom makes a pretty good Sammie
you know and then boom you break out the
lunch bucket they're like you know go
with it no no factor yeah you start
freaking out about this stuff
gonna drive you crazy so yeah be careful
don't freak out about stuff if you have
to learn to stand your ground a little
bit but don't just start snapping good
dog yeah like a rabid dog yeah that that
that is a good little escalation that
examples yeah escalating of a dog nice
piece because sure I mean getting
treated like a doormat that could look
like a bunch of different things you
know it's teasing that seems like the
obvious one or whatever but you know
that could be a lot of stuff yeah that
could be like hey grab me some coffee
yeah right sometimes people just do that
cuz you haven't ever said to him like
you know like hey man are you ever gonna
get me coffee well you don't just make a
joke about the same thing yeah exactly
like dealing with it like as a you know
if something bothers you so that and I
could see this may be happening cuz
every once in a while like you know you
kind of run into these scenarios where
like someone does something that you you
don't really like or you don't I don't
appreciate the way they treated me right
there during that scenario and it sort
of always happens but it's too small to
make a big deal out of it at that time
and when you're a agreeable person yeah
you're just like alright yeah I'm gonna
essentially I'm gonna let it slide
whatever you know but it happens again
then again but I'm agreeable I'm letting
it slide haha maybe I'll even lock it
off whatever so to the other person
they're just like whatever they're just
so how you said they're not thinking
about this is great about their business
and they're getting a laugh here and
there which instantly gets forgotten and
whatever they keep going about their
business no no no factor meanwhile in my
head I'm like man I'm tired of this I'm
straight-up so what happens one day
maybe I got a little less sleep that day
or something one teeny-tiny thing from
flying off the handle
hey I don't appreciate this this and
that you do you always do it and they
are like these artists because even if I
did I didn't get any so then you get
this little reputation people act
shocked as the guy says you know when I
stand my ground it's the other person
it's kind of like why are you standing
your ground right now it doesn't make
sense like even if I did remember all
the times I've done this you were
laughing the whole time like it doesn't
compute it was already now that I know
what I think I think about times my life
like when I was younger then someone
would stand their ground on me or
whatever and I'd be like you
I'd be the exact person that you're
talking about saying what are you
talking about man like I have no idea
what you're talking about yeah why are
you freaking out right now
yeah and then you would say stuff like
that and maybe I put together okay baby
I do make whereas now that I'm older if
someone wants to freak out like that on
me I would instantly recognize thinking
myself like you know what I probably do
things that I shouldn't I probably oh
yeah I kind of ride this person that's
why they're freaking out right now yeah
a little bit more aware yeah of my
impact yeah and but in a way you sort of
had to I mean I'm sure you've sort of
you're sort of familiar with this you
know even like painting that picture
it's like it's obviously you're familiar
with yeah yeah you know but when it's
happening to you you're kind of not but
then if you have to go go back and do
like some investigation of your whole
like relationship with a person to
understand okay now I see how that could
have been interpreted back last year and
then maybe three months ago and then
maybe last week and then like right now
okay
I'm after you know then it it but it
doesn't compute naturally you know so
yeah if you do that the escalating dog
yes thing it'll it'll be more clear I
think yeah maybe an escalated dog only
escalate the dog scenario if you can't
just have a good time with it and relax
and not worry about it yeah which is the
primary goal yes but being treated like
a doormat like I said like if you know
like people were just so you know people
people please their type of person like
in a relationship or something like um
you know like I can't think of an
example but of a movie references very
pathetic anyway if you like a
people-pleasing you do everything for
you know and then they don't do it back
you know kind of thing like oh yeah you
let your you know husband or wife or
whatever you let them go out every
Saturday just because they want you they
want to go play poker or you know one of
these things that what's the common
thing that they do and they do and they
come back late on drugs but no way it
would be way worse than that it'll be
just a total like whatever you need or
want you got it and then like the one
time they say hey I want to go shopping
on this shopping well you got to do this
you got to do the kid you know like that
kind of work where it's like a
disproportionate like relationship you
know
a thing like that can I can see how it
can go down with those types or you know
like beneath it you can't just laugh
those things off no in life you know you
do have to do the escalation of just be
like hey that's a little bit more
serious yeah yeah true X wish hey joko
I'm business owner in the beginning
stages of merging with another company
the other company doesn't know much
about what we do but has the sales and
marketing marketing we need just at a
conference with just that a conference
call with them and it didn't go well
they're wanting to change the pay
structure for contractors as well as
change how we build our customers all
the all for the benefit of money
chi-ching yeah save some money on that
one isn't it not a good idea to have
have the primary mission be about money
and more so on the success of the
customer or is it good to be money
motivated I I have and enjoy all your
books
oh that's cool the advice would be you
know so that means you've read the
dichotomy leadership because it is this
is the answer of the day need to be more
balanced okay so if you're money hungry
right which is what this is sounding
like if you're money hungry correct if
you're money hungry you're gonna cut
corners on product the product is gonna
be weak or low-quality
you're gonna do wrong by the customer
right because when you when you get a
chance to you know the customer the
customer placed an order a double order
by accent they click the click thing
twice
and it'll just enough to pay that
restocking fee you know whatever like
whatever the thing is right you treat
customers like that they're gonna go
okay well we don't really want to shop
with you anymore and you end up with a
bad reputation and the quality is low
and no eventually you have no more
business that's what's gonna happen
so so no we can't go hardcore
money-grubbing
just that's our that's our focus other
end of the spectrum is hey we're paying
our contractors too much can it's that
possible yes it's possible you're giving
your customers too much you're giving
them too good of a price point and guess
what's now we're gonna happen same thing
you're going to not have a business
so one you have a you your business goes
out of business because your because you
don't have any business anymore because
you've treated your customers bad and
the contractors don't want to work with
you so you have you end up shutting down
this one's opposite you're you everyone
loves you you just don't have any money
so you're going on a business you so
there has to be some balance you have to
find the right balance that's what every
company is trying to do now I would say
that you would you where you want to
lean and this is probably what you're
thinking you want to lean toward taking
care of the customer you want to lean
toward giving the contractors good value
for their work you want to lean toward
high quality the reason you want to lean
towards those things as those are all
long-term strategic payoffs right what's
the short term the short term is take
advantage of the customers the short
term is screw over the contractors the
short term is put out low quality stuff
we make good profit this quarter yeah
but it's it's a short-term win it's a
long time long term loss so that's why I
would say lean don't go out of control
you can't go out of control in that
direction but you can lean towards that
direction now as far as the new company
the merger and all this stuff get it I
get it
here's what's gonna happen what you need
to go and build good relationships with
those people the new company they need
to be your best friends because if you
build relationships with them then you
can have influence over these points if
you have an antagonistic relationship
and you're the new guy or whatever like
oh yeah the new company you you think
they don't you're saying that event what
did you say they don't know what we do
right what do you think they think they
think you don't know what they do
they're thinking you know what you don't
even hey you guys make good might make
good product but you can't sell anything
we got sales and we got market we could
sell anything we don't care what it
looks like we don't care what the
quality is that's what they're thinking
yeah so you need to form a relationship
with them because I will tell you with
their sales and marketing if you're
making a good product that's how we get
the big-time win but if you have an
antagonistic relationship with them
it'll all fall apart and you won't have
any influence at all and they'll be like
you don't even know what you're talking
about dude
we're just gonna Jack the price even
more and we're gonna undercut our perk
contractors we need contractors
competing with each other they're gonna
hate each other they're gonna hate us
but it doesn't matter look at our bottom
line so build some relationships their
next wish I'm conflicted about where my
loyalty lies I have a wife and two
children but I recently took a job
within federal law enforcement and based
on my prior tactical experience I'll be
given the opportunity to attend a
two-weeks selection for a position as an
operator on a full-time tactical team
that will most certainly pull me away
from my family my heart is in the right
place I know this level of sacrifice is
needed in order to keep evil at bay
however I believe every father feels
that obligation to be at home to raise
the children and I'm learning that
balancing duty responsibility loyalty
commitment to family to country is hard
and may be impossible
all right so oh yeah and he goes on to
say that I know you have made this
decision yourself yep and I would say to
this dude actually you are the only
person that can make this decision and
you're right I did make that decision I
did 20 years and I at the end of 20
years decided to prioritize my family
over the military and over my own
desires too because believe me the
selfish thing is just keep getting after
it but also what's important I was not
good at balancing right I've I ranked
and prioritized the teams above my
family the whole time I was in and not
everyone does that some people are much
better at balancing than I did and
that's how they do 30 in 32 years and 34
years and 27 years they've figured out
how to balance that better than I did
and so it sounds like you're even
raising this question indicates to me
that you probably have a decent chance
of being able to be better at balancing
than I do
so there's that the other thing I would
say is you say that the being operate on
a full-time tactical team will most
certainly pull me away from my family
I would research that a little bit you
know because sometimes when you get to a
little higher level you have more
flexibility and you might might actually
have time to spend with your family
might be a little bit different maybe
you're hauling to call whereas normally
you wouldn't be on call the novice on
your on call but your while you're on
call you're at least you know you're you
might be doing you might have more
family time I don't know I can tell you
that you know sometimes depending on the
way you look at it you know if you look
at the Special Operations community
versus the conventional community and it
just depends on the units depends on a
lot of things but sometimes you know the
conventional forces go on a you know 16
month deployment to Iraq and that's a
long time some special operations units
going on four month deployments and
they're come home now they now they
might do more of those over their career
but again that's something you need to
you need to find out the facts you need
to talk to someone that's on that team
and say hey listen here's what's going
on I got two sons they wrestle and they
do jujitsu and I'd like to go to those
tournaments what's our schedule like how
is it gonna be you know and then you
kind of you can make a better assessment
I wouldn't just assume that the tactical
team has a busier schedule I could be
wrong I could be completely wrong what
what you're probably the assumption
you're making which is a decent
assumption is that when you're part of a
part of an elite tactical team you're
gonna have to input more time it's gonna
it's gonna it's gonna mean more to you
and you're gonna be like okay I need to
train more I'm gonna tell you should
train more no matter what position
you're in right you need to be training
as much as you can you need to be
staying sharp so I would do some
research on that and then I would also
consider this men have been leaving
their families so they could go and
fight evil since the beginning of time
whether it was they were going out to
fight the Lions or whether they were
going out to fight some we're going to
invade other countries or gonna find
treasure or whatever whatever they were
doing people have been doing it even
world war two guys left and there's no
guarantee that they were coming home
they left for two three four years
those that's the way it works doesn't
your boys are not going to be there not
their lives aren't going to be ruined if
you're not there at every ball game and
I'll tell you there's actually if you do
that your sons will learn the meaning of
duty and sacrifice more than a normal
kid would so so pay attention to that
too again all that being said this is
something that only you can make the
call on because you're you can analyze
the details of the situation and you
know what if your wife works or your
wife works or that wife doesn't work
that makes a big deal if your wife works
and you're gone all the time that's a
problem now who's raising your kids you
got to pay attention to that if you--if
you both work but you both work normal
jobs now you're home and you're don't
you're you know you're there enough so
just weigh these things out but I would
I would get the details and then make a
decision and you know what no matter
what decision you make it's the right
decision how's that that's pretty simple
you're if you make a decision and you're
gonna go on the tactical team cool if
you don't cool you're still doing
federal law enforcement awesome
keeping the keeping the monsters at bay
yeah the thing that helped me a lot that
you explained early on is to tell them
why you're tell people why you're doing
what you're doing you know the team and
in this case the family or whatever and
in this specific case probably your wife
yeah so if you're feeling that because I
did it I did that the feeling of like oh
I feel like I'm not being as loyal to my
family because I'm like focusing on work
yeah kind of thing so I'll get that from
time to time you know especially if I'm
like super focused and it's like dang I
didn't think about my kids or family all
day today you know I'll have that little
fun whatever I did yeah and I used to go
like four months I'm thinking about my
family or such horrible well it's a
sliding scale so you know but I do know
that the more I communicate with my wife
and be like hey I have to go here and
I'm this is what I'm gonna I'm gonna
really try to focus on this you know
this week you know so he video this week
and you know I am busy yeah I'll be be
so I might not be here for this in this
and you know like I might miss this you
know and just lay it all out why you're
doing it you know how you always say and
a lot of the times your loyalty will be
demonstrating demonstrated with that you
know like it's like hey I'm doing my job
it's the time requirements are a little
bit more or whatever like I want you to
know like what can I can we do anything
can we adjust anything to make it better
for everybody
you're onner percent right and and
actually to take that one step further
including your wife into the
decision-making process where you're
like hey listen hon this if I do this
job it's gonna be more but a it's gonna
be super rewarding to me and sometimes
that's enough you know you tell your
wife this is gonna be super rewarding
for me because I'm gonna be able to go
and kill bad guys which is or protect
innocent people which is what I want to
do that's what I signed up for and I'm
gonna be able to do it in a in a more
complete way and there's a chance your
wife says you know what I know that's
what you're born to do go do it or she
might say listen you've done that
already
you know let's focus on the family and
you cool yeah those are both good
decisions yeah we're in a win-win
situation here yeah that's the bottom
line dude next question chuckle I'm 19
and my in my first year at college ever
since I was 12
I've dreamed about being a marine or
seal I plan on joining up after college
but I just got diagnosed with epilepsy I
only have seizures in my sleep so I
never noticed them I always thought of
serving in the military as a way that I
would prove to myself that I was a man
and that it would be it give my life a
purpose now I don't know what to do I
hate the idea of living some comfortable
life where I have a cozy nine-to-five
job that I only do for the money
I want something hard and meaningful
what should I do
there's an infinite number of options
that you have so you need to just pick
one of those options find a new career
of that you think looks cool and then go
get after it and you got a figure you
want to you don't want a nine-to-five
job Cole there's all kinds of jobs that
are nine-to-five you know whether it's
construction management construction or
gas oil or
some kind of public safety there's all
kinds of things I don't know if you can
be a firefighter I don't know if you can
be a cop if you have epilepsy I'm not
sure but there's all kinds of different
jobs and careers and there's jobs that
are hard and there's jobs that are
incredibly meaningful to our economy
here and the more you help our economy
here the more you help us have a
positive influence in the world so go
and figure out what job that you want to
do and go crush it and go you don't
build an empire and make a ton of money
and then if you want to great then you
can support some veterans causes and you
can give back that way so so that's cool
there's there's it's always impressive
to me we work with all kinds of
different companies a national on front
it's always so impressive to me when I
meet people from every possible industry
that you can imagine and they're
completely into their job they are so
into their job they're fighting World
War nine like they're that into it you
know they're run an Intel they'll run an
Operations they're driving down every
dollar matters everything that they're
doing they're so into it and it's
awesome and and this is everything this
is every different industry I see people
like that no not every person in every
industry is like that but if you find
something that you're interested is in
and you jump in there and that's gonna
be your vocation right now there's
another part to this that is kind of I
guess like in your head or whatever
that's like some kind of hard living
that's not that's not very difficult to
come up with right go start training
jiu-jitsu go start training some box and
go start wrestling go do muy Thai go
start shooting go start lifting and
seeing how strong you can get and seen
how powerful you can get go learn to
hunt and learn to hike and learn to play
guitar and learn just learn a bunch of
stuff become a force to be reckoned with
and
you know the bottom line is being a seal
or being a Marine
does not prove that you are a man there
are plenty of losers in both of those
organizations and so don't know you
don't need some label to make you a man
that's not what makes you a man
be your own man go out and conquer your
part of the world
next question two questions I recently
attended an assessment for retraining
let's say one more thing hmm sorry when
things like this happen like when
something happens to me this is you want
to hear my weird superstitious view of
the world sure it's sort of it's sort of
reminiscent of everything happens for a
reason you've heard that everyone's
heard that for me something like this
when something like this happens to me
when something happens in my life that I
didn't want to have happen when I didn't
expect to happen I get an unpleasant
surprise I look at it and assess it like
okay this is this is happening
so that's something else this is trying
to prevent something else from happening
to me that I would have been really
catastrophic I hurt my knee the other
day doing jujitsu
doing doing wrestling and I you know I'm
on my way driving home I'm like you know
what this is preventing me from wrecking
my shoulder in two weeks or the next
night I was probably gonna wreck my
shoulder which is which is you know a
catastrophic injury on my shoulder
that's what was about to happen to me
and the powers that be knew the only way
to get me off the mat was to hurt my
knee bad enough that it pulled me off
the map for for a couple weeks there's a
boom there you go here you go Jocko
you're welcome yeah so something like
this this is an indicator far as I'm
concerned you have some bigger and
better thing that you need to do so
hey it wasn't this yeah that's cool
accept it like right on say thank you
because there's people that they it's
not epilepsy that they have they have
something that debilitates them from
doing even things that you are capable
of doing so be stoked that this delivery
came from wherever it comes from
whatever it is that you believe in that
this dis dis god this happened because
it's it's putting you on the path I
guess that's what I'm saying yeah
putting you on the path so who knows
what you're supposed to do but you're
supposed to do something because you're
not supposed to be a seal you're not
supposed to be a marine if you were
supposed to be that that would happen it
didn't happen that's not a bad thing
that means there's some other doors
gonna open up big yeah so that's the way
I always look at injuries like that yeah
the most positive way I can look at
injuries is hey I was going to whatever
I was gonna look like I was gonna rip
apart triple threat on my knee in four
days so I just got a little ding to pull
me off the mat so that doesn't happen
yeah oh I needed rest here's what you
get boom you're gonna get this yeah I'll
have those thoughts do some yes like
it's kind of like oh I'm safe from
injury because I'm already injured kind
of thing yeah it's like there you go so
weird feeling yeah but that is true and
yeah and kind of like a lot of times do
it and this is so good that that guy
this guy is he knows already I want to
do something harden me bro
I'm man 19 1999 him yeah he's totally on
the path and you know he's just
discovering what doors he wants to you
know what doors are open while the doors
are closed whatever you know and he's
disc up man when I was 19 yeah I didn't
know direction dude did I ever have the
thought of hey yeah I want to do
something hard and meaningful did I ever
have that thought hmm no I did not have
that thought ever waits or something
this but yeah man that's good so yeah I
think you yeah yeah there's no there's
no label that makes you a man you do
Jack and you're doing a good job so far
all right next question two questions I
recently attended assessment for
retraining into the combat control
career field I'm active duty for Air
Force in a different career field and
rang the bell
during water confidence training how do
I live with my decision and move forward
yeah and there's you see there's two
there's two questions that are basically
the same question so that was part a and
this is Part B I do read do hard deal
art okay drop on request
gotcha I'm wearing the belt same thing
so I deal art from buds class 303 I went
went on to be a SAR CORS CORS me star
swimmer star swimmer corpsman so here's
a he's a rescue swimmer okay but it's
Tatum but it's taken until recently to
regain the desire to live and even
strive to work out again what can you do
when you realize a life path you've
chosen was not only wrong but you never
feel like you found a new path to me
this this question both these questions
are kind of similar to the previous one
right and I can tell you being a being a
seal or being a combat controller is not
the be-all end-all and the bottom line
is it wasn't for you it wasn't for you
it wasn't even you don't want you guys
it just wasn't for you and the fact that
matters it's not for most people it's
not normal
there's an 80% attrition rate of but
most people quit good people I was down
there the other day and osakan one of my
buddies that runs runs it runs he's a
civilian but he's one of the civilians
that works there but he was we were
talking about you know what it about
buds and I forget what even led into it
but he pointed at that you know when you
when you quit but you put your helmet by
the Bell and so as more and more people
quit important more helmets are enough
and there'll be hundreds of helmets
lined up and he's like you see those
helmets right there and I'm like yeah he
goes every single one of those kids was
a stud and when I went through it wasn't
quite like that because not everyone
that was showing up at Budds in the 90s
was a stud sir the they weren't because
we didn't know what was happening we
didn't know we didn't know how to do a
pull-up workout we couldn't look online
and see a program on how to get better
at rope climbs we didn't know that you
had to swim with fins we didn't know I
didn't know what I didn't know anything
when I showed up to buds so these kids
now they know everything and so what do
they do they prepare all of them at a
minimum I would say the minimum guy
prepared now is probably prepared at
least as good as the most prepared guy
actually that's probably that's probably
inaccurate I bet you the minimum the
least prepared guy entering buds right
now is probably still more prepared than
the most prepared guy that went to buds
when I went through now so so my point
in saying that is most of those people
that are studs quit most of those people
that join the Navy that sign on a dotted
line and commit six years of their life
because there's nothing more they want
to do than be a seal and most of them
don't make it through so it's not for
everyone and then you know what you
you've one guy in the airforce one guy
in the Navy you did your job you did
we're supposed to do a corpsman whatever
your normal career field was in the Air
Force and you served your country and
you did what the country needed you to
do the country needs you to do whatever
job you did the country needed you to do
that job so thank you for your service
and now you go and find something else
you go and find a new mission and the
same things here like you want to get
better with your life so what do you do
you work and you build and you study and
you get an awesome physical condition
and you train jiu-jitsu and you become a
doctor or a firefighter or EMT you're a
cop and there's whichever way that you
figure out that you can serve you become
a business person you go and work
construction whatever it is that you do
you go and do it you do it hard and you
don't get caught up in a title right so
this is another thing it's kind of
reflects back to we were talking earlier
eels don't care that you weren't a seal
you know like it's not like seals are
walking around going oh this person
wasn't a seal I don't respect them this
person wasn't see I don't respect him
we don't care it's a vocation it's a job
so you know I don't look down on people
that weren't seals it's just that was my
job you had a different job right it's
it's like it's like jiu-jitsu I don't
look down on people that don't trained
jiu-jitsu I look at them like hey you
should because that's a choice mm-hmm
but let me rephrase that I don't look
down on people that I can beat in
jiu-jitsu because I know for a fact all
it is is that I've been training longer
than them and once they train longer
than me they'll be able to beat me
that's the way it works
so people that were in the SEAL Teams
aren't looking down on you because you
weren't they don't care I'm not thinking
about it so when I meet a cop when I
meet a firefighter when I meet a
business person I respect what they're
doing with their life if they're getting
after it I don't care what arena it's in
man I know some I'm so lucky right now
working national on front we meet people
that have just just awesome humans that
are crushing their field and if they
were in the SEAL Teams they'd be
crushing that field but they didn't they
went to what they went and did what they
did they went in the finance world they
went in the construction world they went
in the gas oil business whatever they
did they did and they're getting after
it so that's what you need to do you
quit in the past you rang the bell no
one cares
unless you quit now
so get up go find a new mission and get
after it man get after it
next question
you've been unfairly wronged by a
brother mm-hmm
objectively hmm you aren't getting the
full apology that you expected the beef
is over now and he treats you well but
how do you psychologically reframe and
kill that lingering resentment unfairly
wronged by a brother interesting
brothers don't wrong brothers we'll
start with that so this dude wasn't
actually a bro a brother met him in a
brawl but he wasn't a brother you make a
little distinction there is that
distinction never been made before I
don't think on this off platform they're
making it cool there's like hey this
guy's my bro it's all good and then
there's like this guy's my brother my
brother is not gonna wronged me my bro
might but my brother's not gonna wronged
me so that he so if it happens some guy
like I said if somebody that you
consider your brother wrong is even that
clearly you you overestimated their
really commitment so here's what's gonna
happen me number one it's noted noted
that's my that's my ultimate that's my
ultimate satisfaction right when I note
when it's it when I note something yeah
oh it's like oh this is the kind of kind
of person he is noted right now I got
him now I got this person marked so
Trust is not gonna be reestablished
for a long long time if ever mmm-hmm
right I'm not gonna like this person
clearly but here's the deal all that
mistrust and all that dislike and all
that is gonna be internal I'm gonna keep
it inside because you know what I'm
gonna have those inside I'm in a harbor
that I'm gonna harbor those things even
this resentment I'm gonna harbor it
because I can't I can't just make it go
wait you-you-you wronged me it's gonna
be there yeah but you know what I'm a
professional externally I'm a
professional even if we're not a
business even if it just like hair I I
trained you just do it
right I'm a professional so I'm not
gonna let his little maneuvers get me
externally worked up about it it's not
happening you don't get control my
emotions like that external you might
control them inside but I won't let you
see that ever so I'm a professional I'm
a normal face that's where I'm coming at
you from just normal face Hey
all good oh yeah and you know what's
interesting this behavior so when you
screw me over and then I just go okay
check noted and then I don't give you a
reason to like hate me and then you kind
of owe me yeah you know what I mean
so there's that and there's a there's a
fine line like if you screw me over and
then I just allow it to happen and it
was a it was a violent violation well
then there might be have to be
repercussions right it sounds like this
did not warrant repercussions mm-hmm
because you know there's certain
situations if somebody wrongs you in
certain ways there has to be
repercussions to me normally most of the
time the repercussions and the best
revenge that you can take is is to
ignore now perform and be successful in
rock on and forget about them and forget
they even exist it that to me is the
best possible way to go because why
would you let somebody interfere why
would you commit any time effort
resources to revenge when I would the
better thing to do is commit those time
resources energy to success to winning
yeah I'm gonna do that but if this
merits some sort of repercussions okay
then those get carried out and if those
get carried out well then we're we're
kind of settled but he says you didn't
get the full apology you expected it
sack okay then hey guess what people are
arrogant yeah that's the way it is they
don't think the guy didn't think he did
anything wrong most likely he's not even
apologizing for it barely so that's what
I do I'm just gonna keep it professional
I'm gonna you're gonna be subconsciously
indebted to me whether you know it or
not yeah you probably know it you'll
probably feel
because I'm just gonna okay cool yeah
we'll move on but Atman you know the
thing is this is sort of goes back to
that other kind of topic today like this
guy isn't going around thinking about
you
yeah so why are you thinking about him
let's move on man let's move forward and
it seems like a big part of it right
like that it seems like he was he says
you aren't you aren't getting the full
apology you know like remember on that
Seinfeld that apology dude I was talking
to someone I was talking to someone like
a blanket apology I was talking to
someone that we both know whose will say
up a public figure and this individual
was reading YouTube comments and getting
legitimately like emotionally distraught
about the whole thing yeah and was was
trying to talk to me about it and like I
said man I literally do not care like I
do not care like this is no factor you
don't need to warn me you don't need to
tell me you know what I need to look out
for like I literally don't care yeah I
mean if someone writes a good YouTube
comment good it's funny that's great if
they write in a mean one cool I think
those are funny too
yeah I'm not I'm not worried about it
the person that wrote the YouTube coming
isn't thinking about me yeah you know
they're not try they're not they're not
reviewing it again yeah and writing it
again and you know like they don't care
I'm not getting all caught up in this
stuff don't caught up in these petty
things you know I did that we talked
about this on the podcast of of of the
black belt the black belt doesn't care
about things that don't matter you can
grab the the black belts shoulder of his
gay and he's doesn't care because he
knows that doesn't mean anything there's
no there's no that's no factor mm-hm so
you wanna that's that's what you want to
do you wanna you don't want to care
about things that don't matter you don't
invest your time and energy things no
matter the guy wrongs you cool noted you
know that he's kind of a kind of a
a devious dude you know that it's noted
cool move on yeah no I'm not worried
about it am I gonna put my trust in him
again
no but that's cool cuz I know other
people to trust yeah well let's not get
wrapped around these little things man
let's let's let's let's let's let's rise
above get some Black Flag going here
let's rise above I still wonder what
kind of polish I'd totally cut you off
so sorry but yeah and I is the Saint
felt thing it didn't matter the but I'm
wondering one at the same time what you
saying I agree but mm-hmm I do wonder
what kind of apology he got you know cuz
he didn't get the full apology near
partial yeah so well partial apology
that can come in many forms yeah it's
probably the most common form of a
partial apology has a butt on it yes
yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry we did swing by
and pick the others up the other night
but I just didn't even know that you
wanted to come yeah yeah kind of like it
was my fault I'm sorry but yeah it was
partially your fault kind of thing and
then there's the other one that's like
I'm sorry you felt that way you know you
know that one worth like hey I'm sorry
you felt that that I was attacking you
you know but you know I didn't mean to
kind of thing where it's kind of like
hey you're because the person doesn't
want an apology for necessarily the
actual words you said it was it was like
what you did mm-hm like you attacked me
with whatever you said you know kind of
things so you can't just say hey I can't
I'm sorry I start I'm sorry that you
felt that way
yeah you know that is a pretty
backhanded sort of yeah same thing but
the but well the one you say but I'm
sorry but you know I didn't know that's
kind of like I'm sorry but I'm not fully
like yeah that's the same are you saying
with extreme ownership yeah that's when
people say you know look I'm in charge
of the team and this was definitely I'm
in charge of team when I'm in charge
didn't didn't when things go wrong it's
my fault but I'll tell you what sorry
yeah sorry yeah and my way from time to
time well where are no excuses
yeah there's nobody think about it when
you get somebody that actually believes
in extreme ownership there is there are
no buts on anything that they say and
strangely I mean kind of I guess
coincidental incident i Ryan and I are
old daughter who will not allow you to
make an excuse you know their old
daughter yeah she will call you
if you throw a but or you say well I
didn't know when we had to be there oh
so you're not taking ownership yeah yes
yeah totally makes sense and if you it's
strangely like if you do it without the
but you know when you do it just full
speed even if in your head you believe
but I mean let's face it man you had it
coming to you kind of did yeah just keep
it because that's not what you're doing
when you apologize that's that's
separate from the apology you know it's
like you're including this stuff
unwarranted stuff with your apology
don't do that give a good apology in
original work is the worst thing is is
it's so obvious and it makes everyone so
mad oh yeah the receiving end of that is
so mad and you think that it's you think
that it's improving your position yeah
cuz my look I would look hey echo I'm
really sorry that you showed up to
record and I wasn't there and I didn't
let you know but yeah but I didn't
really I didn't remember texting you or
whatever like like but you know you
should have told me that you were
heading that so that's the whatever yeah
but you should have told me that we were
definitely recording because you didn't
really get back to me yeah like why
would I say that yeah all's I'm doing is
you know what's funniest people always
tweet me when a sports coach they tweet
me when a sports coach either takes
ownership or doesn't over yes not
overtly cuz some guys some sports coach
to say hey look I'm the coach I made
some bad calls out there we're gonna get
back in the drawing room I'm gonna get
this thing fixed
and if it goes man this guy's awesome
and it's just so funny everyone says
this guy is awesome he's taking
ownership even people that aren't even
people will retweet something that they
people aren't saying he's taking extreme
ownership so I want to say oh it's good
to see a coach taking full
responsibility or whatever they'll use
their own word for it and then some
other knucklehead sure look we'll we'll
say you know um I am the coach and I'm
responsible for the team but if I got
players that aren't gonna put out over
in the fourth quarter yeah you know you
got to carry out totally embarrassing
friend everyone says hey you might want
to learn how to take ownership yeah and
that's where people so it's so obvious
and yet we still do it
we still throw out the butts we still
want to clarify our position yeah don't
clarify your position
say sorry take
ownership knows it my wife will watch
these nobody call it the housewives one
not the show like the reality show ones
you know the whatever Housewives of
where and men riddled I think that's why
she watches it just to see the
trainwreck I think that's what I think
is my suspicion but men yeah they're all
arguing with each other and then you
know they're crying and then the one
will say they'll just they'll say the
perfect example of the non-apology you
know every single time yeah man it's
like it hurts your heart to watch but
you kind of like you kind of dated
I wonder I wonder if this is because
this is what happened with this guy just
I just figured it out right now I really
don't know but this is what I think okay
theoretically yes there was a guy
relationship there was a what a girl guy
relationship okay you know
boyfriend-girlfriend scenario you know
maybe this guy got drunk the bro the
brother bro
whatever got drunk maybe hit on the girl
maybe something happened maybe something
did it oh and then it was like hey sorry
about what I do with Christine last
night I was super hammered yes but I was
super hammered yeah exactly right and
that's a big one that's a big but in the
apology you know but you know we all had
I remember someone sent time someone did
I won't go into it doesn't matter but
it's a big one yeah it's a big deal or
it's a big common one we wronged by a
brother but no it was my like parents
friend okay it's lady and she like she
was talking she was talking shit about
my mom to my dad and I was there they're
hammered or whatever I'd like some you
know things and she's like totally
talking she talked about this I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna do it so I'm like
whatever I'm like a TI maybe 15 16 years
old oh maybe maybe I don't know whatever
but you know and a teenager I wasn't
like a three-year-old you know so I
heard and I knew what she was talking
about it was rude who's uncoolest on Sat
mm-hmm as we say and some like cool all
right go home eight I tell my mom
straight up
so I mom's like oh whoa okay you know
tells my dad blahblah my dad tells the
lady and the lady of course is all like
you know like I did this and you know so
she comes to me and she says sorry right
like sorry for this or but we had you
know we had a lot to drink or whatever
and all this stuff and I remember
feeling that like how is like how does
this make it better you know when you're
like but we had so I'm thinking that and
I didn't know anything about drinking I
don't know what it made you sort of do I
didn't really know at that time so to me
it was like wait so wait when you drink
like you can do that kind of stuff or
what like what's the the deal and the
the apology just basically bounced off
me like bullets off a Superman or
something yeah you know I'll probably
don't put the butts on those things yes
so that's what happened with this guy
that's what I think possible but it is
his responsibility like you said to be
like hey I can't hold on to this thing
you know like what do you say how do you
psychologically reframe it and kill that
lingering resentment thing is that it's
like a scar you have to - he's like
keeping it a wound you gotta aim at it
yeah and you gotta be like that's just a
scar it's like sure our relationship is
different now just guard now deal but
man I got more important things to think
about
do whatever yeah if you can pull that
off you be good
move on next question hello and thank
you sir I'm an inner-city math teacher
an OG hardcore kid I successfully
approached my students as a team that
I'm the leader of how do I discipline
some of my key players and at the same
time boost or at least not lower morale
awesome well that's cool I would say
this if you've got kids in the classroom
and they got key players in the
classroom do what I always say to do to
people
put them in charge of stuff man and put
them in charge put these kids in charge
of things in the class not just dumb
stuff either not just clean up not just
sweeping the floor but some legitimate
stuff like hey I want you to come up
with a lesson plan for tomorrow here's
the book that we're looking at here's
the pages I want you to talk about dang
I want you to lead the discussion that
we're gonna have in class hey I want you
to go over how you solve this math
problems tomorrow
you got you got some of the problems
wrong on the test I want to teach them
to you and I want you to teach the class
because obviously I didn't do a good job
maybe you can do a better job than me
and you know what you you you're kind of
you kind of loud let's put that to use
I know people listen to you here's
another thing kid the kids look at you
look at you and they look up to you
let's use that let's try and get kids
moving in the right direction so that's
what I would do in a situation like this
if someone's actually getting in trouble
I wouldn't you don't do this you don't
do what I'm talking about
because they're in trouble right that's
a little bit you can't say you're in
trouble so you're gonna have to teach
across to me no no that doesn't work you
say you say hey you let that whatever
they got punished for you use you know
your punishment that could be something
like taking out trash yeah but you don't
want to throw leadership at someone when
they get in trouble occasionally you can
do it occasion you can be like okay you
know what you're in charge of the
platoon for this week or for these four
days of admin and all of a sudden yeah
you realize oh you got a comment at five
o'clock in the morning oh you got to
stay until 1800 at night oh you got
these reports - oh yeah it's like all
these things that you didn't think about
that's what you've got to do and when
you get off that restriction and you get
out of that role you realize hey I have
a little respect for the boss because I
realized what the boss is going through
so that's what I would do have some fun
with this put the kids in charge of
stuff give them little assignments make
them get up make them turn them into
leaders
turn them into leaders check we think
one more what do you do when you fail
and how do you handle it what do you do
when you fail
you know recently we reviewed that US
Army Field Manual on here from like
World War 2 era and it says in that
manual it says other than death
all failure is psychological other than
death all failure is psychological think
about that just just just think about
that this failure this upset this this
catastrophe if you aren't dead then it's
just psychological it's in your head now
this does not mean that you won't lose
some battles because you will we all
will
but it does mean that as long as you
don't surrender as long as you don't
give up as long as you don't quit then
you haven't failed just means you've
made a a temporary tactical retreat
means you've made a a brief withdraw so
that you can regroup and we attack so as
far as I'm concerned if you get beat
unless you're dead you are not defeated
and you have not failed what you've done
is you've learned you've you've gained
experience and you're still alive
then you have memories to make so get up
and go get after it
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight
so echo Charles yes speaking of getting
after it
sure getting after it can you help us in
that category yes so we are on the path
part of that part of that path like we
always say is jiu-jitsu it's funny how
like you'll say do you like when you
would suggest someone to or your
suggestion for someone to like move on
or to like you know get out of a rut or
whatever you always said you did yes and
rightly so
yes you know it's one of those things
men where I I'm not psychologists I know
you know that but I think that it'll
cure various levels of Defense real hey
I've taken a lot of flack over that yeah
I've taken a lot of flack over that I
think Joe Rogan sure when I was on his
you know we were basically saying like
worked out you know feel better and
never got all mad right
but the funny thing is Tim Ferriss who's
actually gone through that kind of
depression will tell you the exact same
thing yeah so yeah work out work out and
do jiu-jitsu for sure
yeah it's crazy with you know why I'd
say dude it's even more than just like a
regular workout whatever that even means
um is because you have a challenge
that's a little bit more obviously like
you against like an obvious challenge
you know and for you against the person
there's that okay and then there's the
physical part of it of course like the
workout part of it which is one of the
best workouts like if I wanted to like
lose 30 pounds right first I don't know
whatever if I want to lose 30 pounds
like bad pounds right so I you know and
right now as of right now there's no way
I would do like a weight loss workout
I would just do regular weightlifting
and I would just do more jujitsu that's
it 100% like why would you some screen I
mean jiu-jitsu is such a good workout
yeah why would you work out muscles that
you didn't know you had your whole body
today
by the way whole BOTS yeah even your jaw
muscles yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
everything especially you with the jaw
muscles because you spend a lot of time
on the court or the back pocket
terrain or coincidentally that's another
part of it is what I was about to say so
aspect 800 for you for everybody yeah
for you to in have a little conversation
oh yeah post training yeah even like
between rounds whatever it's like you're
doing it and sure you can do that at the
gym kind of but it's different or what
it's weighted he won't want to talk
before training I protest that you know
I protest it I start block Brett - gobe
okay the five minute rounds are on you
guys are rolling video then enough of
this chitter chatter here's how
prevalent the social element is you know
no and you'll agree with it because it
happens with you too so you ever like
shaking kids clock started beep clock
started you shake hands with a person
and then you just sneak in one question
to the person like that socially no not
all the time because like the time you
know you remember like I'll do with
great I'll do it I won't joke about that
Oh like we'll talk about our day like
Andy and I will joke about yeah yeah
like beep clock starts and it's like
how's work today do yeah yeah yeah
basically what it means is neither one
of us feels like training yeah laughs
and then we'll train right because we
won't we won't actually have a
conversation right but see how you know
that it's a it is a thing it so much
that you make jokes about yesterday's if
that's how social it is you know and
Matt's like no I just gotta tie my belt
and adjust my D and put my knee pads
back up and you know what I mean yeah
yeah there's another stalling tactics
yeah not very social but yeah it's
stalling for sure um but there's a lot
of this thing that we call jiu-jitsu
about shoes
those you just bought anyway that was
the site no anyway when you're doing do
do so of course you need a geek because
you're doing G and nogi so when you get
your key what keys are we getting or
even the best skis or we getting the
drunkest skis we're getting the best
skis
all right oh yeah big time Becky's our
origin geez you get them at origin mein
kampf or that means dot-com there are
all kinds of stuff all kinds of clothes
including jeans if American which you
know what even like not everyone does
jiu-jitsu not everyone does Gita Jitsu
but everyone does have jeans now let me
ask you the same question you asked me
what kind of jeans are we getting best
kind not the junk is not the junk would
you say junk is John Kista that's not
even a word is it it is not the junk is
the kind it is if something is junk
oh you know what it's just one of those
subtle differences in in in remember I
told you in court in Hawaii they're like
subtle differences in words there are
only small they're pretty much the same
but they'd sell them that is one of them
like junk you got a little pigeon yeah
as a little pigeon Liz it would be junk
iasts right not junk yes exactly right
so junk is the same as junky like it's
this it's like in the mainland you say
junky like it's just more of a what do
you call it like I've done a ver but um
oh yeah yeah that that hamburgers real
cheap it is real junky right so junk on
the mainland the word junk is a noun
it's a junk it's a piece of junk it's a
pile of junk it's an era in Hawaii it's
a it's adjective like it's junk like
that's a way of describing it oh no no
no see it sounded like a noun to you
because you're from the mainland if you
say Jeff that's why you can have words
like it's junker it's way more junk wave
we don't want the jug cuz there's such
thing as junk junker and junk East in
Hawaii in here it's like no it's just
junk it's either junk or it's like not
junk you don't kind of thing come on now
seems like I said these differences are
subtle gonna follow though ya know cuz I
thought of like if you went if I said
hey what's that stuff on the side of
your house over there echo you'd be I go
that's just junk right a pilot that's
junk and I get what you mean by that
it's an old lawn chair it's an old weed
whacker that doesn't work anymore right
yeah a couple stuffed animals that no
one wants the one that's junk yes so
what you're saying is hey how's that car
that you just bought yeah how does it
work how is it is that thing they don't
know is it dope you're like
it's junk how was that movie last night
kind of junk hmm yeah so I'm with in
regards to jeans you don't want the junk
jeans or in your case the junkier
junky esteems junk list is what you said
her ass the whole Hawaii version Hawaii
yes that's how unless the best one get
the origin jeans and whatever other
clothes and don't forget about
supplements too supplements joint
warfare krill oil discipline discipline
go discipline go for when you need a
little kick and and it's interesting you
and I have both morphed to a situation
where discipline the drink is just the
normal that's just part of the world
that's just part of it yeah I am now
drinking and this is the thing about
discipline it doesn't have 480 grams of
or 480 milligrams of caffeine yeah in
fact it has 15 grams per scoop this is
not the crazy stimulant that's like
let's face it jiu-jitsu you don't want
to be all amped up on caffeine going to
jiu-jitsu class how do you get it that's
why discipline is so good
pre-roll yep so that's what I figured
out now is if you have iced tea which I
used to drink a lot of iced tea yeah
drink jakka white tea right you you just
drink that stuff
right like think of when you were a kid
all enough some iced tea that I caffeine
in it right
you weren't freaking out that has been
way more caffeine than discipline so
what I'm saying is discipline is now
just sort of a good to do just a day
long like an all-day I must have had I
must have had five bottles of discipline
today
dang okay yeah yes that's more today
because I'm sitting there drinking it
you know I'm working yeah I'm writing
I'm editing which is rich let's face it
like writing and editing sometimes is a
real chore yeah mental chore there's not
fun yeah so you got to get eaten no game
yeah that's why I've been trained a lot
have been disciplined lately a lot of
writing a lot of mental thought yeah so
anyways you don't know the megamix for
jujitsu is discipline mm-hmm okay
water you
can actually add like a look like a
maybe like a third cup whatever the
third of your mix total of like a
cranberry juice or like um you can
squeeze lemon juice in there or
something okay water lemon juice
discipline and on it has these like
minerals and electrolytes mix one scoop
of that boom that's the jiu-jitsu
megamix libretto bring you through go to
do two scoops of discipline three if you
want to get nuts mmm
you gotta add more water you know and
then you got that situation going or
whatever spend times where I've made
discipline shots okay like I like eggs
okay you know what I'm heading to
jiu-jitsu I'm gonna be there in three
minutes
oh yeah yeah I'm just up a little shot
it's got three scoops and it's it's like
a shot yes I've done that before but
that's also why I meant discipline go
yeah because this one glow is for those
situations where you don't want to drink
a bunch but you just want that hitter
yeah but the go the pill that that takes
longer though right because not instance
yeah the instant that's why I taste it
I'm like I don't know half an hour forty
minutes prior to yeah
event situation evolution it's like here
they have loosed it mine I feel like is
or it is straight up it's like a routine
you know like you sort of have a routine
and class you know I got some routines
yeah yeah the protocol comes into play
like this you go boom okay I got you
just at xx time right I leave the house
at X time - whatever I drink the megamix
x time - whatever - you know another 10
minutes so it's like the the amount of
time it takes to mix it on and just tell
everyone when to drink it if they're
gonna roll or do something active oh the
thing is I don't saw 40 minutes my half
an hour forty minutes half an hour
I'm sorry 40 minutes mine as I leave the
house so I'll have mine cause that's how
long it take to get here between 15 and
20 minutes okay so what you don't need
it to kick in right when you get here
cuz you can be chat with people for the
first time hour
yes it's one of those things it's not
like there's this little teeny tiny
window of it working
it's in the in the system right you're
rolling around only oh yeah you don't
even really like feel it like we're off
or nothing like a coffee crash or
nothing like that
so I don't know I just do it that way
that's been and it's worth like man I
won't not do it that way yeah
also don't forget about milk which is if
you need extra protein which you do you
can get it from milk or if you just want
a straight-up dessert you just have
dessert and if you don't think the
strawberry milk tastes like dessert
you're wrong you know the strawberry
milk is dessert get some and some of the
other ones I've just had so much of them
I'm just really stoked on a strawberry
right now mint you know what it was your
go-to peanut butter or is it mint mint
but all the interchange for variety
whatever that straw everyone came in
thanks Brian for that by the way so it's
like okay you know strawberry Slater
there's a lot of height it's strawberry
cool I'm not the hugest like I like I
like the strawberry I like it yeah but
when there's chocolate like why would
you do strawberry you know if you have
chocolate or whatever so I'm like but
whatever let's do it the strawberry was
is so mix it up boom the same deal I
didn't want to like add extra stuff in
there I just I wanted to raw a deal so I
had regular milk and strawberry milk
there are few types all about
surprisingly surprisingly good meaning
and I don't you know that's a general
term surprisingly good or whatever to me
the strawberry milk tastes closer to an
actual strawberry milkshake the only
difference that I could detect is that
it's not as like overtly sweet as like
one from like a you know like you get a
strawberry milkshake foot place you know
it just wasn't as sweet as that that's
it I don't put another half a scoop in
there and you'll be in the zone you what
so I implemented the that hater the real
litmus test right soy what do you call
unless the kids sit down I was like this
is strawberry milk have some just a
little thing so here's how you do it you
don't say is it good is it not good
because if they're not into you want
more you don't even ask that we just
wait so because if you ask a
is it good or not good daily if they're
old enough they'll tell you what you
want to hear no bleak yeah good then
they'll go play or they won't be into
the tests at all which typically they're
not and they'll just be like no it's
junk therefore you know in their mind he
won't give me any more or whatever you
know you just don't get an actual action
and accurate reading so what you do see
here you can have some of this that's it
so they tasted both of them wanted more
mmm both of them that's me yeah that's
what it is really good so and also don't
forget warn your kid milk that comes in
strawberry and chocolate as well and
it's it's
it's like legitimately good for your
children so get it for him
oh yeah also chocolatey yes chocolate
some teeth called chocolatey yeah and it
just is like drinking goodness that's
what it is like drinking victory
drinking tastes like tastes like victory
and it's just goodness got antioxidants
get you little gets you a little kicker
certified organic tube by the way yeah
yeah so that's that really cool orgy
mein kampf forgot to say that yes
also taco has his own store taco store
to go to Jocko store calm this is where
you can get your discipline equals
freedom shirts hoodies lightweight and
heavyweight hats hats hmm no you know no
heavy weight hats you know but you do
have those trucker hats with what do you
call it snapback or flex fit so some
options there mmm anyway anyway you want
to represent the path you can get
something there rash goods as well
jiu-jitsu or whatever you're doing boom
you can get a little shirt that says
good on it that does not have my head on
it which is a positive thing moving in a
different direction more subtle
direction I don't necessarily agree
because I think that the one with your
hand on it is like has not very subtle
bro does that's not only at all but it
does like now they both have their
benefits because look when I wear the
good one just just good I like the
people who do say something they're just
kind of like oh yeah good good they'll
just say it
you know but the one with your head
they'll either ask oh who's that
on your shirt like who is that usually
it's like I don't know you know Winston
Churchill is I don't even wear a public
figure in there
so they're wondering who is that and why
that we got to do that the first thing
that you know and I've overseen a
Winston Churchill t-shirt when I'm glad
that we got that going nonetheless or
they'll know who you are and they know
that that's what you say and they'll be
like you know what do you call it the
book that when they know and you know in
a feed yes exactly right so I did both
hundred percent fun molest a lot of cool
stuff on there if you uh if you like
something get something as they say also
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
already on iTunes and stitcher and where
ever you listen to podcast because a lot
of places they're trying to kind of
change the landscape of podcast
listening to by the way oh yeah yeah
they want to charge money or something
put it behind the firewall hey I think
it's pay well pay wall maybe the
firewall to firewall the pay wall
anyways we're free we're free free but
nonetheless hey it is really you have to
pay you know what you have to pay you
have to listen to this part of the
podcast you don't actually even have to
do it's like one of those little trays
don't forget about the warrior kid
podcast which is also not behind a
paywall
it's free for your children if your kids
want to learn how to be on the path your
kids want to learn about Desa but if you
kids want to learn how to handle
bullying and trouble in school and
trouble study if they want to learn
handle all that stuff in life I mean if
you want to get a little into cuz you
know you need it and get some of that
warrior kid podcast yeah that's also
Irish Oaks ranch calm this is where you
can get weary kids so yeah which is not
for kids
yeah it's actually Jocko soap made by a
warrior kids is worried kids so called
Jocko soap there's another edition
called trooper so or is it the trooper
bar trooper Soper yeah nonetheless it's
today it's good yeah yeah this is good
so awesome yes it'll help you stay clean
it'll make you stay clean mmm in a
hardcore kind of way
also youtube if you are interested in
the video version of this podcast of
Jocko telling us helping us advising us
do you advise them just over here saying
my point
I guess more than anything else yeah and
then and then echo makes videos that
he's super proud of and he's all hype
about and he thinks they're super cool
so you can check those out too yeah yeah
there you go
nonetheless yes YouTube jockle podcast
YouTube channel yeah you have one so
yeah we do have our own YouTube channel
yes you can sign up for little
announcements sure that come out no I
have that so whenever you post a video I
get a notification yeah and I go oh cool
echo post a video should i watch it yeah
and then I go down and read the comments
it goes looking drew yeah so there that
Beth comment in the world but yeah and
then psychological warfare you can get
that if you need a little little
assistance during a challenging moment
of weakness
if you press play on your phone you can
play a little track that will get you
through that moment a weakness it's on
iTunes Google Play and B through
platforms of all kinds and if you want a
visual representation to help keep you
on the path checkout flip side canvas
dot-com where my brother Dakota Meyer is
making art we pull a nose and he's
putting into the art with layers that's
what it is there you go you just you
just going to use made the motto art
with layers we're gonna put some warrior
kids stuff up on there for your kids
rooms we're gonna put some warrior kid
things up there so be checking that out
and if you have anything that you want
to have on a canvas let Dakota Meyer
know well I hit him up on Twitter tell
him what's going on tell me what you
think he can make he can make it happen
so there's that also on it on it calm so
this is where you can get your
kettlebells when you're when we are
varying up our workouts need more
kettlebells
you need more functional fitness type
stuff that's where you get it also like
I mentioned before the the mineral /
electrolyte mix for the free jujitsu
actually pre-workout to megamix this is
where you get it on it calm / Yakko what
if you I mean you don't
you know what a pre-workout is it's
called a pre-workout yeah it's like it
has like Faizal dilators and caffeine
and stuff in it it's mainly for like
lift you know whatever you can mix that
if you work out don't do met Khan's on
this but if you just lift him for like I
poured your fee or whatever and you like
pre-workouts you mix that in the mega
mix so you go pre-workout discipline two
scoops one scoop electrolytes from on it
lemon juice water mix that report back
whoo that's the mega mix right there for
lift information measure your biceps
report back yes yeah your pump will be
out of this world but before jiu-jitsu
don't do the pre-workout don't do the
caffeine before that's my thing anyway
on it calm slash Douglas where you get
it got some books got some books coming
out I got one book coming out called or
way the warrior kid three where there's
a will I think we're in this podcast now
we might even be live or close to it
yeah so way the warrior kid three order
it immediately I just got the numbers
prior to walking in here it's already
selling like pretty awesome so
appreciate everyone pre-ordering it but
if you want it order it now so I can
print enough for you because the
publishing company is Darko publishing
also we got--we the warrior kid one we
got way the warrior kid to subtitle
Mark's mission way the quarry way the
warrior kid one subtitle is from Wimpy
to warrior the Navy SEAL way teacher
kids be on the path of if you got a
little bit younger kid get Mikey in the
Dragons Mike in the Dragons will frame
your child's mind to be able to overcome
fear for the rest of their lives just a
nice little thing to give them for the
rest of your life you don't have to be
afraid of anything
yes there you go there you go child
you're welcome discipline equals freedom
Field Manual that's how to get after it
the audio of that is on iTunes Amazon
music Google Play another mp3 extreme
ownership and dichotomy leadership both
those books I wrote with my brother life
Babin and we take the experiences we had
in combat overseas the leadership
lessons we learned and
we pass them on to all of you also we
have echelon front which is our
leadership consultancy and what we do is
we solve problems through leadership and
if you want to have us come and work
with your company and then go to a salon
front comm if you want to come to a live
experience you can come to the muster
May 23rd and 24th of Chicago sold out
you won't be coming to that one
September 19th and 20th in Denver not
sold out yet but it will and December
4th and 5th in sydney australia go to
extreme ownership calm all of them
they've sold out all of them will sell
out so get in the game early EF online
this is our if you can't make it to the
muster but you want to get granular with
your leadership capabilities then go to
EF online.com and we will take you
through leadership courses that will
pragmatically improve your leadership
skills there's interactive decisions you
have to make in those courses so check
it out EF online.com and then EF
overwatch if you are a business person
and you are looking for leaders which is
what you need in your company you need
leadership if you want leadership in
your company we have a special
operations at combat aviation veterans
and we are getting them placed into your
company so go to EF overwatch if you are
looking for leaders in your company and
if you want to cruise hard more with us
on the interwebs Twitter Instagram and
on Facebook of course I'm at Echo
Charles and chocolates at Jocko will Inc
what are the three platforms Twitter
Instagram and then Facebook oh thank you
thank you
I wasn't quite sure what you said and
thanks to everyone out there that wears
the cloth of our nation a military
uniform thank you for your sacrifice and
thanks to you
our families as well who also sacrifice
to keep the nation safe and thanks to
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers Border Patrol Secret Service
all first responders for what you do
every day and thanks to your families as
well for supporting you so that you all
can support us and everyone else out
there remember that life goes by like a
summer day and you don't have time to
get hung up on failures you don't have
time to dwell in the past and you can't
preserve the memories perfectly so make
sure you get out there every day and you
make new memories by moving forward and
getting after it and until next time
this is echo and Jocko out